thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story Prince Harry fighting
hatred and harassment at the high court
the first Royal to face
cross-examination in more than a century
in his case against press intrusion he
cites the impact on his mother and says
Piers Morgan's alleged involvement made
him feel physically sick I
oh and unjustified what do you think
I didn't see it
but I wish him luck with his privacy
campaign I look forward to reading in
his next book
also tonight the flood of war the dam
destroyed close to the Ukrainian front
line potentially blocking the
battlefield inundating civilians homes
we're in one of the main streets
of Pearson City and even whilst we've
been here it's risen a couple of inches
I'd say
plus from influencer to allegations of
rape we speak to a British woman who
says Andrew Tate threatened to kill her
welcome to live 2023
Ting up a major row of a golf's future
as the biggest tours team up with a
saudi-backed rival
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
foreign
it was far from a traditional Royal
Court with cross-examination replacing
curtsies Prince Harry faced a full day
in the witness box in his case against
mirror group newspapers and in his
testimony written as well as spoken he
didn't hold back he said he had played
up to headlines that he was a thicko or
Playboy Prince and said the alleged
actions of former tabloid editor Piers
Morgan made him feel physically sick
there are no cameras inside the high
court but we've shown what the Duke had
to say voiced by an actor our home
editor Jason Farrell reports
press scrum at the Royal cause to
witness one Royal's Crusade against the
Press
Harry believes he can prove the tabloids
were liars and law Breakers
but according to his biography spare
Harry's father described his son's
lawsuit as a suicide mission
now we would see we've used an actor's
voice for Harry's witness statement the
tabloids would constantly trying and
coax me a damaged young man into doing
something stupid that would make a good
story and sell lots of newspapers
looking back on it now
such behavior on their part is
utterly vile in his cross-examination
The Mirror's lawyer began by arguing
that Prince Harry hadn't read many of
the Articles at the time so couldn't
have been distressed by them citing ones
written when he was a boy there are no
cameras and no recordings in court but
this is what the Duke said in response
performed by an actor
these articles were incredibly invasive
and each time one of these articles were
written it had an effect on my life the
people around me my mother in this case
her reaction to me as her son
then came across examiner's next line of
attack
the mayor's lawyer Andrew Green is that
much of the
infantary says was a was obtained by a
league
was actually already out there either
from Palace officials or other
newspapers or even Prince Harry himself
one example an article on Prince Harry's
18th birthday green says the private
information has been revealed by you in
an interview
it was argued that information in this
article about his mother visiting him at
school on his birthday was announced by
the palace the day before that this one
about his broken thumb like many others
merely copied information from other
newspapers and broadcasters Prince Harry
was asked whose phone he thought had
been hacked for the information the
doctors I'm not sure I can't be sure Mr
Green are we not in the Realms of
speculation asked the mirror's lawyer no
I don't believe so again I'm not the one
who wrote the article you'd have to ask
the one who wrote the article
Harry seems to be keeping his cool he's
not rising to
that's to his credit I think so far
we've had a lack of detail from him as
to precisely how these days the unlawful
information gathering has taken place
Prince Harry often referred to invoices
and payments to private investigators in
his statement saying there were eight in
relation to his mother it was suggested
in court that Princess Diana's phone was
hacked when the Daily Mirror was edited
by Piers Morgan who in recent years has
been a vocal critic of Harry and Megan
reference to this was also in Prince
Harry's statement the thought of Piers
Morgan and his band of journalists
earwigging into my mother's private and
sensitive messages in the same way as
they have me
and then having given her a nightmare
time three months prior to her death in
Paris
it makes me feel physically sick
hello
motivations this was Piers Morgan's
reaction he said your behavior was vile
and unjustified what do you think
I didn't see it
but I wish him luck with his privacy
campaign look forward to reading in his
next book
Harry also claimed private investigators
were paid for information that led to
these articles about his relationship
with Chelsea Davey and the intrusion
ultimately caused them to break up
specifically asked what information was
obtained from hacking for this report
about a trip to Mozambique Harry said
this uh the paragraph that says
Harry will fly back to Britain on
December 19th that not only is that a
security issue I can't begin to imagine
how they would find that information out
without blagging
now flight blogging could have been done
through phone hacking either way I'm not
entirely sure how these journalists one
of those being Jane Kerr how they would
ever know what date I'm flying
and having the confidence to put that in
a national newspapers
advertising my travel plans
to be his best moment the paper's lawyer
tried to counter that while articles
were sometimes intrusive and
embarrassing the prince lacked evidence
they were obtained illegally Harry often
made the point that the journalists who
wrote the articles should be quizzed
about their methods many are not coming
forward to give evidence for a man
probably more comfortable on a
battlefield than in a witness box making
the point that he's had the guts to be
cross-examined Jason Farrell Sky News
well our correspondent Laura bondoc is
outside the high court Forest tonight
and Nori you saw him in court today what
did you take away then from Prince
Harry's evidence
but we always knew this was going to be
a historic day but it was an utterly
extraordinary one as well a senior Royal
the son of the king testifying at the
high court and doing it voluntarily this
isn't what the royal family does it
hasn't happened in living memory Prince
Harry's legal team were happy with what
happened today and they would of course
say that but I think it does show there
were real worries about how he would
cope under the pressure of quick fire
cross-examination but if the mirror
group Barrister had hoped to go Harry
today it didn't happen Harry remained
composed and calm but he wasn't given an
easy ride he was facing some very direct
and difficult questions about what kind
of proof did he have that all the
stories that were written about him
involved or were the direct result of
illegal activities like phone hacking it
really was intense but don't forget this
is what Harry wanted he wanted it all
said dead and heard in open court
because he has this higher purpose a
bigger Mission which is to prove what
went on but also to hold those
responsible to account his witness
statement felt like a Manifesto he says
he had a front row seat when it came to
hacking and that will all be better off
as a result of this case day one is done
but there is plenty more to come
tomorrow when the cross-examination
continues
we'll see how coverage then Laura thank
you
so Prince Harry chose to bring his case
at the high court but he's facing an
unwelcome challenge in the United States
tonight our U.S correspondent Mark Stone
joins us now from the e Barrett
Prettyman U.S courthouse in Washington
and Mark this case is over the terms on
which Prince Harry entered America
yeah it's fascinating stuff I don't
expect any resolution to it soon but it
certainly was a stroke of legal
coincidence that on the same day that
everything was unfolding at your end in
London here at this federal courthouse
in Washington DC the phrase the Duke of
Sussex was uttered many many times I sat
in court as they went through some some
pretty complicated and not wholly
relevant legal details that is the setup
of a a legal argument which could see
the prince in some rather a rather
difficult situation essentially the
Heritage Foundation which is a
right-wing Think Tank here in the United
States which has got it in for the
Department for Homeland Security over
how it issues visas has found a perfect
case study in Prince Harry because Harry
lives here he was granted a Visa and yet
he has admitted taking drugs on multiple
occasions he's admitted it in his book
and in his Netflix series so the
question for the Heritage Foundation is
how was he allowed to get a Visa because
there are two specific questions in visa
forms for entry to the United States
which say essentially have you ever
taken drugs if he answered yes to those
questions then there is a question for
the US government why did they let him
why did they give him a Visa if he
answered no to those questions well then
in the words of Nile Gardner uh a uh a a
senior person at the um Heritage
Foundation he lied he committed perjury
which puts him in an incredibly
difficult position this for the Heritage
Foundation is a political story they've
got it in for Biden in the White House
they're a right-wing Think Tank Biden's
government is Center left but also it's
personal Nile Gardner from the Heritage
Foundation has written a number of times
about his views on Harry on Megan as
well so as I say he is a neat case study
he ticks a number of boxes we won't yet
we won't know for some weeks whether or
not his Visa could be revoked
Mark in Washington thank you
but you can get plenty more analysis on
the Prince Harry case and more of our
reconstructions on the Sky News website
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen you can listen to the latest
edition of The Sky News Daily podcast
where Leo boletto and our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock take you
through everything you need to know
about the Duke's appearance in court
it is too early to say for sure that the
detonation of a dam which is inundated
parts of a key Battlefield in Ukraine
was carried out by Russia that was the
verdict tonight from both the White
House and Rishi sunag on his way to
Washington but military analysts told us
that the short-term benefit of the
explosion would be to Russia's Advantage
they never kakov kadam is in Ukraine's
Hesson region which is currently under
Russian occupation Upstream the dam
helps Supply cooling water so the
zaparicha nuclear power plant Downstream
it was holding back water which is now
streaming across low-lying land
including the city of Hassan our special
correspondent Alex Crawford is there
the breach of the Nova kakov kadam is
being called Europe's largest man-made
environmental disaster in decades and
Ukrainian officials lost no time in
calling it a terrorist act and an
international War crime
the unleashing of the torrent of water
from the huge Reservoir swallowed up
whole streets dozens and dozens of
villages and parts of hairson City
within hours
residents scrambled to safety with their
pets just picking up what they need
whilst neighbors and relatives hastily
set out to find stranded elderly family
members who can't Wade through these
Rising Waters
and others watch from their Windows as
the water just Rose and Rose
I don't know what to do lidmiller says
how can they do that okay it's War
soldiers are fighting each other but to
blow up the hydroelectric Dam I can't
find the words it's Barb Barrack
the water is really Rising quite rapidly
just to give you an idea of how deep it
is this is one of the the plant pots and
we're in one of the main streets
of hairson city and even whilst we've
been here it's risen a couple of inches
I'd say
the people of hairson City have been
occupied and they're regularly bombed
and shelled so being deliberately
flooded isn't phasing them when you live
here for more than six months after
being bombed all the time
after being scared all the time so it's
scary but not so much as you're bombed
all the time
we're trying to stay safe the president
called an emergency meeting of his
Security Council and left his East
European Partners in no doubt who he
thought was to blame
um
the damn Blast has wreaked havoc on both
sides of the dinipro river including the
russian-controlled territory on the
Southeast Bank plunging vast areas on
that side underwater too Russian
officials have denied their responsible
claiming the Ukrainian sabotaged the dam
because of their failing
counter-offensive Association
is
on City that's not how they see it
normal people will never do that he says
about the damn blast they're just
terrorists
what can you call this she tells us it's
genocide of a Nation
misery again for the civilians but the
floods will also likely tie up Emergency
Services as well as impede the Ukrainian
forces and their plans for a
counter-offensive Alex Crawford Sky News
in care Swan City
while the breaching of the dam in
southern Ukraine is being discussed
tonight at the United Nations security
Council America's representative said it
wouldn't make sense for Ukraine to be
behind the attack so what benefit could
come from the breach or International
Affairs editor Dominic wyckorn reports
the huge novakov kadam seen by satellite
before its breach and after almost
completely overwhelmed or Swept Away
suddenly the terrain of War across a
swathe of Southern Ukraine looks
completely different a potential
Battleground now under millions of
gallons of water at what could be a
pivotal moment
the breach of the dam has flooded one of
the most crucial fault lines of this
wall that runs the length of the danipra
river
in August Russian forces retreated from
land they taken north of the river to a
new defensive line along it and dug in
in trenches and fortifications on and
south of its Southern Bank in locations
marked here with red spots
it's not clear how flooded those
defenses are but the river itself is now
an even bigger obstacle for ukrainians
to cross
temporarily at least greatly advantages
the Russians Ukraine is quite clearly
it's beginning its counter-offensive and
it's got a lot of choices about where it
attacks the rise in waters the flood
will make it more difficult for the
ukrainians to attack across the river
the breach comes after this a marked
increase in fighting in Ukraine over the
last few days is this the start of
Ukraine's counter-offensive it's not
clear but if it is then Russia May well
be taking preemptive action at enormous
cost again to the people who live here
and there's this to worry about too the
waters held back by the dam are used to
cool the nuclear rods in Europe's
biggest nuclear power station at
zapparesia the world's nuclear Watchdog
the iaea says it's watching the
situation closely
the war has taken another Lurch in an
unexpected Direction with many more no
doubt to come Dominic wagorn Sky News
a woman who says she was sexually
assaulted by the social media influencer
Andrew Tate has told Sky News that he
threatened to kill her he is currently
under house arrest in Romania as police
investigate allegations of human
trafficking rape and sexual exploitation
of women a warning that our crime
correspondent Martin brunt's report
includes graphic descriptions of the
alleged violence right from the start
we were having sex and he put his hands
round my throat and strangled me until I
lost consciousness
and when I came round he was still
having sex with me a young woman who
says she was the victim of sexual
violence and rape her attacker she says
was social media influencer Andrew Tate
with all these chicks just stuck in her
house sitting there bored completely in
love with me tate is facing a claim for
damages from four women in the UK three
who worked in his internet sex business
and Alice not her real name who says he
strangled her how close do you think you
came to being seriously hurt the next
day one of my eyes all the whites of my
eyes had got completely red in one of my
eyes
and I looked it up afterwards and it was
just lack of oxygen to your brain where
your blood vessels start bursting to try
and get more oxygen into your brain that
was quite scary why didn't you go to the
police I was worried that maybe I would
get blamed they would say well you were
having sex with him anyway it's kind of
your own fault
Alice says she met Tate in a bar in
Luton the town where they both lived it
was 10 years ago they had two one-night
stands
she says it was the second in which Tate
turned violent that's why she's planning
to sue him
I just hope that he can be held
accountable for what he's done and
spread the message of Education about
consent and hope that more women might
feel comfortable coming forward with
stories of stuff that's happened to them
not necessarily by him just in general
the lawyer representing all four women
said they wanted to see Tate in court
civil or criminal our clients have
suffered immeasurably and they've
suffered significant loss not just the
the physical harm that they alleged
occurred but also the fact that they've
been unable to work because of the
trauma they experienced and so they're
perfectly entitled to seek compensation
there's no embarrassment there's no
shame in that if it can help them
rebuild their lives so be it a spokesman
for Andrew Tate said he vehemently
denied the women's claims did not
condone violence of any kind towards
women and had only ever had consensual
sex he's now under house arrest in
Romania suspected of rape people
trafficking and exploitation his UK
accusers he said we're trying to take
advantage of his current situation
Martin brunt Sky News
ITV management were accused today of
making light have claims that there was
a toxic culture at the this morning
program questioned yesterday the
program's editor had said that what he
really found toxic were aubergines this
true and angry response from MPS on the
commons culture committee as our arts
and entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer now reports
two was toxic I've always found toxic is
aubergine do you like aubergine it was a
bizarre encounter with the editor of
this morning I don't like aubergine it's
just a personal thing outrageously
flippant
was a select committee described Martin
frizzell's bizarre vegetable-based
response as for the first time in the
Philips Schofield Scandal one of itv's
big bosses was given a grilling that's
surreal performance by the editor of the
program who when he was being asked by a
reporter from Sky about bullying on the
program started talking about aubergines
this is the person who's responsible for
safeguarding young staff let me reassure
you Mr Nicholson uh that we take it we
take these issues very seriously
well I would I wouldn't endorse what he
said it was extremely ill-judged uh to
say what he did but look I can reassure
you on behalf of ITV that we do take all
of these allegations very seriously
precisely because we do have a culture
in which people's conduct it matters
enormously
schofield's conduct is likely to be a
question asked of ITV Big Boss Dame
Carolyn McCall who next week also appear
before the culture select committee we
don't know whether non-disclosure
agreements have been used we don't know
whether money has changed hands but I
think that's really important to get to
the bottom of it I shouldn't eat things
like this or I can only stay clean for a
certain period of time when I'm eating
something like that the daytime show for
now goes on the Heat's being turned up
on itv's management please welcome your
host fabulous Jane McDonald with its
former star turned persona non grata on
the channel Jane McDonald stepping in to
host the soap Awards a regular gig for
TV presenter Phillip Schofield since
2006 but that was before his own
personal life delivered more plot twists
than your average TV drama
Katie Spencer Sky News
the chair of the covid-19 inquiry says
it is up to her to decide what evidence
is relevant amid an ongoing legal row
with the government Bernice Hallett
refused to withdraw her order for the
government to hand over unredacted
material from former prime minister
Boris Johnson as a preliminary hearing
got underway
it was a majority that any politician
would respect the new boss of this
Scandal hit CBI told us today as her
plans to secure its survival were backed
by an overwhelming proportion of its
members not among them though were some
of Britain's biggest companies who cut
their ties of allegations of sexual
misconduct and rape our business
correspondent Paul Caso has more
a step forward for the woman charged
with salvaging Britain's biggest
business Lobby group armed with a
thumping mandate to reform the
scandalized CBI I think a majority of 93
is one that any politician would respect
and I think what we've shown today is
that we've got the support of our
members and now we want to sit down with
policy makers look at the economic
evidence look at the insights we're
getting from businesses and talk to them
about the critical challenges our
economy faces the CBI has been cut
adrift by some members and ministers
following claims of a toxic culture and
two allegations of rape and unconnected
misconduct claims against former
director General Tony danker that cost
him his job at an extraordinary general
meeting the remaining members delivered
a thumping mandate for reform asked do
the changes we've made to reform our
governance culture and purpose give you
the confidence you need to support the
CBI 93 voted yes and just seven percent
no from 371 votes cast business has been
very much about profit and about you
know the bottom line well now we
actually have to look at culture sure we
have to look up behaviors I think
they're showing they've really addressed
these particular issues but you don't
want to throw the baby out with the bath
water and destroy the good parts Blue
Chip companies like NatWest BT and John
Lewis that resigned their membership are
not rushing to return leaving the CBI
short of cash as well as credibility so
this member has faith in the leadership
it's not a culture that I recognized and
it's not the people that I recognize
the people that I know at the CBI and
that's you know a lot of the reason why
I'm standing here today is because of my
personal connection and personal trust
in each and every one of the people that
are at the CBI today the cbi's challenge
now is to try to win back the trust of
some of the biggest companies in Britain
that walked away when this Scandal broke
and to regain credibility in Westminster
so that ministers and the opposition
start talking to it again you can't have
one without the other and the CBI needs
both if it's to regain its position
the CBI hopes to again lead British
business having offered an object lesson
in what can go wrong
Paul Kelso Sky News
Saudi Arabian money has already landed
the country's football clubs two of The
Game's biggest stars and now tonight the
country also has a stake in the most
prestigious tournaments in golf the
saudi-back live golf tour is merging
with the PGA and European in a move
denounced by families of victims of the
9 11 attacks our Sports correspondent
Rob Harris reports
welcome to live 2023 our first official
first they split the sport now they've
taken it over the goal Feud sparked by
Saudi Arabia's Rebel live League healed
by a stunning unexpected truce and we
will be investing in the growth of the
game of golf it's a historical day for
the PGA tour in the game of golf there's
been a lot of tension in our sport over
the last couple of years but what we're
talking about today is coming together
to unify the game of golf Hal betrayed
will players feel who stayed loyal to
the PGA like Rory McIlroy to block the
Breakaway last year the PGA had gone to
court denouncing Saudi Arabia's
deplorable reputation and human rights
abuses but lucrative signing on fees and
prize money in Thai stars to join the
Rebellion this golf tournament is taking
place 50 miles from Ground Zero it's
disgusting and faced Anger from families
of 9 11 victims still demanding
accountability from the Saudi government
for the terror attacks it's what human
rights activists see is sports washing
by the regime just a reminder it's Saudi
citizens who suffer first from from
repression in the country but golfers
football players women athletes and
others LGBT athletes they're not immune
from suffering as well
and there remains opposition within golf
with PGA Tour player Wesley Bryant
saying I feel betrayed and will not be
able to trust anyone within the
corporate structure of the PGA tour for
a very long time but the Allure of Saudi
wealth goes far beyond one sport
hours after the golf deal was announced
five-time Champions League winner Karen
Benzema signed for a Jetta team
following another former Real Madrid
star Cristiano Ronaldo in making the
move to the kingdom
both with clubs now owned by the same
500 billion pound fund behind live golf
and the Revival of Newcastle United well
that's making athletes even wealthier
and the sound is even more powerful in
sport Rob Harris Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10. coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this on Prince Harry's
evidence on the front page of the Daily
Mail which says he must have longed for
the schmaltzy embrasive Oprah well
tonight we are joined by the observer's
chief leader writer Sonia soda and the
former conservative special advisors
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
just a moment the Press preview a first
look at what is on the front pages first
though a reminder of our top stories
this evening Prince Harry has been
cross-examined in his hacking trial
against the mirror group and condemned
the Tabloid press as vile
a state of emergency has been declared
in southern Ukraine after a dam was
destroyed leaving a nearby Town
reportedly underwater
Sky News has spoken to a woman who says
controversial influencer Andrew Tate
raped her and threatened to kill her he
denies the allegations
[Music]
well hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer Sonia soda and the
former conservative special advisor
Salma Shah welcome to both of you so
front pages then let us start with the
Metro describing Prince Harry as having
been given a reality check during his
high court testimony with the mirror
groups lawyer insisting his claims of
phone hacking are in the realm of
speculation
The Daily Mail offers an analysis from
the columnist John Moyer who has little
sympathy for Harry
the financial times quotes the Ukrainian
president valora mizalinski saying
Russia has detonated a bomb of mass
environmental damage after the breach of
a major Dam on the danipro river
the eye calls the incident a war crime
and says 40 000 people have been
displaced and the situation in Ukraine
is also the main concern for the
guardian
away from Ukraine The Daily Mirror leads
with calls from Rob Burr's wife tonight
his former teammate and fundraiser Kevin
sinfield
the express has word of a supposedly
game-changing weight loss drug
and the star queries the low rate of
convictions for burglaries across the
country
or quick reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see it on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages for yourself while you watch us so
let's head straight to Our Guest then
Sonia soda and Salma Shaw welcome to
both of you
um some extraordinary pictures today uh
Sonia including the guardian at
environmental disaster you know 100
villages flooded this major city of
Hesson real implications for both the
war the economy and the livelihoods of
people in southern Ukraine
that's right so this Dam that's been
destroyed is an absolutely huge Dam it's
two kilometers long much much bigger in
scale than anything we've got here in
the UK many times more bigger and Richie
sunak the Prime Minister has just issued
a comment tonight in which he calls this
you know the biggest attack on Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure it's really hard
to overstate
um the scale of the damage that this
will cause uh you know the human damage
um to many many ukrainians but also the
vast environmental damage this is going
to have huge repercussions and there may
be lots of knock-on effects um so this
obviously affects water supply it
actually affects uh potentially
um the cooling of a massive nuclear
power station in Ukraine
um although thankfully experts say that
there is a there are enough safety
measures in place that um it shouldn't
be affected for many weeks to come or
being well but this is absolutely
massive in scale and it comes just as um
you know this talk of Ukraine launching
a counter-offensive against Russian
forces in Ukraine trying to capture uh
back lost grounds this this summer uh
grounds that has been uh taken over by
Russian forces so it's a really really
significant event um uh in the war yes
and the Prime Minister on his way to
Washington you know somewhat equivocal
at this stage about who is to blame
um Salma uh he says our military and
intelligence agencies are currently
looking at it too soon to preempt that
and make a definitive judgment but what
I can say is if it's intentional it
would represent I think a Sonia quoted
the largest attack on civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine since the
start of the war and just demonstrates
the new lows that we would have seen
from Russian aggression he went on to
say attacks on civilian infrastructure
are appalling and wrong
um similar from the the White House
discussions at the U.N security agency
but this is hugely significant is it not
and long feared that's the point about
this
oh yeah of course it's hugely
significant and of course of course
there is also a difference in the way
that people are being quoted so as you
say the Prime Minister has had some
Nuance in his statement the Russians
have strongly denied that they're
responsible for this and as uh for as
their form goes uh suggesting that is
it's an act of self-sabotage by Ukraine
um and the president of the European
Council has called it and is quoted as
calling it a war crime um the ukrainians
are calling it an act of Terror so there
is there is some Nuance because of
course it then becomes incumbent on uh
Western Powers uh to then consider what
their response is going to be to this
and assonia's just spoken about
um this also will create some issue for
the war effort on on Ukraine's part
because this is a huge uh catastrophe
which is going to require a lot of
resource from the Army and of course the
government's attention because we are
talking about 40 000 people who are
going to be displaced as a consequence
of this not just the environmental
catastrophe but what this does to
surrounding infrastructure and and we
actually this is the first part of it we
don't actually know how this is going to
play out in terms of the flooding
yes and that 40 000 is the figure we can
see there on the front page of the eye
uh Selma at least 150 tons of oil from
the dam has already leaked into the
danipro river that's cutting to the
environment Minister for Ukraine it's
the dam itself one of the biggest in the
world and certainly the other comments
from Rishi sunak is about you know their
first response has to be humanitarian uh
trying to help all those people who are
fleeing
um or being moved I mean is Russia
moving them to Russia Sonia
well I mean I think that's the question
because
um initially it looks like this is going
to have a much bigger impact in terms of
the destruction destruction of Russian
um controlled areas of Ukraine so what's
going to happen to those um Ukrainian uh
citizens
um I think there's and what kind of
humanitarian efforts are going to be
supplied to them in in areas that are
controlled by Russia I think that's a
really big question I think it's
important to say as well although you
know some people are being quite
cautious before we know too much more
about attributing blame to Russia
although interestingly I think the EU
has already done that a sort of
Wonderland has gone so far as to do that
I think it's important to say that one
thing we do know is that this dam was
controlled by Russia in the run-up to
this um huge explosion and one thing the
ukrainians are saying is this scale of
damage it cannot have been caused by an
attack on the dam sort of uh from the
outside uh it looks like an attack that
that has happened you know from the dam
itself yeah and certainly residents were
suggesting that her son is the garden of
Ukraine I see that wheat prices have
already surged uh one figure of 2.4
another coating three percent has big
implications therefore for you know
feeding other parts of the world so
everyone will be watching closely
because this is ongoing it is still
actively flooding and we'll certainly
keep an eye on that in the meantime the
other big story um Salma front page of
the metro and a number of other
newspapers uh Prince Harry
um they call it his reality check
cross-examined not the Cozy interviews
possibly he's seen before
now indeed and of course this is one of
the great preoccupations of the
newspapers tomorrow because it deals
directly with uh what Prince Harry has
said is uh the practice of newspapers or
certainly was when he was growing up so
there's been some quite emotional
testimony from Prince Harry uh in court
today and as we go through the papers
we'll see a different sort of a
perspective on that
um I mean nobody can sort of deny that
this person has had a very difficult
time and when you go through that
testimony and he talks about you know
not being able to trust people uh
because of these stories appearing
um you know it it's it nobody can sort
of prevent themselves from being
slightly sympathetic if not more so
towards him but the Crux of the issue is
about his allegations around the
legality of how that information was
obtained and that is the contentious
piece that is unfolding in the courtroom
at the moment yes suggestions of you
might have been filmed going into a pub
because or a restaurant because I had a
celebrity chef there it wasn't
necessarily something that been leaked
suggestions that it might have been in
the paper before that's why mirror
journalists were there you know you
could see the pattern of Defense from
the mirror um Sonia during today's
testimony
you can and I think there's going to be
a lot of sympathy for Harry and what he
speaks about
um and what he's spoken about in court
today
um but the issue is that you know the
the the weight is on him he's the person
who has to prove his allegations about
the mirror we know that the Mirror Has
acknowledged and admitted to hacking the
phones of of many people in order to get
stories
um but in this case Harry has to prove
that in relation to the stories that
he's putting forwards those stories were
obtained by the mirror through unlawful
means
um and that's quite a tough bar to
that's quite a tough threshold to cross
in a court of law and that's why we're
seeing the pushback from the mirrors uh
lawyers where the KC uh cross-examining
Harry is sort of putting a lot of
pressure on him and saying well this
this story that was already reported in
the press that you've put forward
couldn't this detail have come from here
so what the mirrors lawyers are trying
to do is sort of say to the judge well
there's no proof here that this came
that this information was was obtained
to unlawful means so it is quite a high
bar that Harry has to clear however I do
think that for you know for Prince Harry
he's been very clear that he's you know
he's going to do what he can to expose
um the part that he feels the Tabloid
press has paid in you know making his
life very difficult and uh the life of
his wife Megan uh uh Duchess of
um uh Sussex very difficult as well and
so you know perhaps for him obviously he
wants to try and prove this in court but
even this getting an airing in court uh
Mike for him you know be part of his
objectives yes and the guardian
um you know using the word vile Prince
Harry said vile British tabloids had a
devastating impact on his mental health
but there were broader attacks too uh
weren't there Salma on the state of the
British press and the government as both
being at rock bottom with the government
having no appetite for for press
regulation
um some commentators suggesting this is
an establishment figure attacking the
establishment
well it's interesting because he sort of
calls out uh the prime minister in his
uh in his testimony uh and he's is
insinuating that there's too much
closeness between uh the the press and
government and I think that to some
extent he's there's a slight naive
perspective because of course you know
journalists hold a government to account
and having been someone on the inside of
government and you know Sonia too
journalists do hold governments to
account they do hold Prime Ministers to
account so I think that some of that is
actually slightly misplaced although you
know he's now no longer a working member
of the royal family and he's perfectly
entitled to have his view on this but it
is just a view
daily mail
um Jan Moyer uh he must have longed for
the schmutzy Embrace of Oprah at last
here we go curtain up drum roll lights
action Here Comes The Judge closely
followed by the Duke of Sussex one day
late
um Etc
um different papers with different views
presumably depending on whether or not
they are subject to this kind of action
from Prince Harry's Sonia
yeah I think that's right I think you
can see um a division in the Press I
think the Daily Mail front page it's
obviously this column by Jan Moyer is
referencing the fact that uh being
cross-examined in court is no walk in
the park and it's very different to
doing a celebrity interview like being
interviewed by Oprah Winfrey for example
however I'm sure Prince Harry was aware
of that before he gave um evidence in
this trial and he he made the decision
that he was going to do it anyway I'm
sure he'll be very clear about the risks
um that there are um involved for him
and anybody who's watched any form of
trial um you know this is a high profile
trial in the high court knows that you
come under quite intense scrutiny from
um barristers from the other side so I'm
sure Harry himself would have done a lot
of preparation with his advisors um for
this moment and I think the fact that
he's come in for some quite Fierce
cross-examination that's not a surprise
that's exactly what you'd expect in a
high profile trial um uh in in the high
court yes preparation but not coaching
that's what I learned and certainly you
can't talk to his lawyers tonight Kenny
before he goes back tomorrow for more
another half day uh from Prince Harry we
are told lots more still to come
including having led the party gate
inquiry Sue gray has now been given the
green light to join labor staff we will
discuss that and more in just a moment
foreign
[Music]
I was on the campaign for a full year
and so I did 71 campaign stops with Mr
Trump I worked on strategy fundraising
Communications and a whole host of
different things we didn't think we were
going to win I can say that to you on
the 8th of November in 2016
Mr Trump was even saying that you know
we didn't think we were going to win but
once we won
I was not going to take a job in
Washington and so that came up and if
you recall in July of 2017 you know my
wife probably dislikes president Trump
almost as much as Melania dislikes him
and so she didn't want me to do it and
so that caused me some personal problems
as well thankfully we patched that up
but yeah it was 11 days or 954
000 seconds sometimes I say it that way
it makes me feel better but it was it
was it was a very interesting time in my
life and I'm glad I did it I learned why
did you want to work for him
well you know I think ego I think
ultimately I think for your viewers and
listeners be very careful with your ego
because when you make decisions that are
based on your ego or your pride you can
sometimes make the wrong decision for
yourself and so you know I built two
successful businesses in the United
States I had gone to law school you know
I grew up in a blue-collar neighborhood
and so I had this self-narrative where I
was going to go work for Mr Trump the
president of the United States you know
sort of from a blue-collar neighborhood
to the White House and it was very
compelling to me to do that July 31st of
2017 was a really bad day for me my wife
had filed for divorce I got fired from
the Trump Administration I was getting
lit up by every late night comedian in
America and every cable news pundit so
it was a really bad day but here's the
good news about that day that day's
behind me you know and I don't regret
any of it and I tell people when you're
having a bad thing happen to you in your
life
get through it you know we just keep
moving keep going and so I think that's
another big lesson from the whole thing
my message to people is we have to heal
the country we have to find a
transformational leader that can reach
into those people and help to rebuild
that trust and re-knit the fabric of
America so Mr Trump is not capable of
doing that remember the first name of
the country is United it's not the
tribal States of America or the dis
United States of America and so we need
I think better leadership more Visionary
leadership more aspirational leadership
than somebody like Mr Trump
[Music]
foreign
thank you
well welcome back you are watching The
Press preview joining me once again
Sonia soda and Sal Michelle welcome back
to both of you
um so we go to sue gray anger as sugary
gets the okay to join starmer with a bit
of gardening leave this has been a bit
ongoing hasn't it Selma
yes and of course normally this would be
a very Westminster Centric story but
were it not for the party gate inquiries
that Sue gray LED I don't think this
would be such a prominent story in the
papers uh so uh obviously Sue gray has
now been officially cleared to join
Kirsten on this team as his chief of
staff and what is unusual about this is
that for many years suit gray has been
an impartial civil servant and there
have been some questions from government
around
whether she was able to conduct uh the
inquiries into the Prime Minister uh
impartially uh knowing that she was
potentially going to be joining the
leader of the opposition's office now
clearly the fact that she's been cleared
and she's going to have a short
gardening leave and begin with kirstarma
in the Autumn means that there is has no
suggestion or indeed evidence of
impropriety on that part but of course
anybody going into a role like that is
going to be facing extreme pressure and
I think it's going to be doubly so for
Sue gray going into that role yeah and
what will the role be I mean the paper
the express suggesting that she will
help ready his party for power after a
general election but this is of course
such a kerfuffle you know you wonder if
it's it's worth it Sonia
well I actually think it you know as
Selma said it is quite a sort of
Westminster focused story but um I think
it sends a really good sign uh to the
extent that people are interested in
this that um kirstama wants to work with
somebody as heavyweight as sugray as
well respected across Whitehall to help
labor get ready for government and
um there's obviously a bit of
institutional support from the Civil
Service for an opposition party in the
run-up to an election but I think it's
very important that labor takes advice
from people who know government inside
out there's a lot of people on the labor
Shadow front benches who've never been
ministers in government they would have
been out of power for 13 years so I
think it's a very good sign actually
that labor are taking seriously the
prospect of winning a general election
and understand that it's not just about
having some snazzy policies you need to
know how White Hall Works um in order to
to make to make an effect change so I
think it's it probably is worth the
hassle to the extent that the public
sort of have concerns about it I think a
lot of the concerns actually are just
being talked up by conservative MPS
conservative ministers who are annoyed
about it but I think the fact that
you've got this independent buddy a
cobra which scrutinizes
um you know the new jobs that former
civil servants and Senior civil servants
and ministers can take on and they've
said six months gardening leave um is
enough and that's an independent view
um so I think labor will be quite
pleased with that actually probably
um quick look at the Daily Star uh
inspector clueless police fail to solve
a single burglary in almost half of
neighborhoods in England and Wales I
mean they're typically a humorous
treatment of the Daily Star but being
burgled is not a violation for people
and very serious isn't it Selma
um
yes and I think why this is interesting
is of course it's the star's take on it
and increasingly I've often found that
the star front page sort of speaks in
tabloides but perfectly to some of the
concerns that are being faced up and
down the country and you're absolutely
right burglary is a very serious crime
it has serious impact on the people who
are victims of it but what we're seeing
actually is a trend and the government
have talked about 20 000 extra police
officers and I think there's going to be
a lot of pressure that's now applied as
a consequence of these figures as to
what is happening with the delivery of
that and when the general public is
going to be able to see the benefits of
it
sorry officers they say are accused of
giving in to scumbags but as I said it
you know it's very very serious for
people suggestion is they've been just
helping just stop oil tarkwinds on the
M25 in 30 seconds Sonia
yeah I'm not sure it's that but I think
it's a mix of things I think it's a
resourcing issue the number of police
officers we've got as Salma just said
but there was also an important report
from Her Majesty's inspector
um on the police uh in recent months
which said that it's not just a
resourcing issue there are um actually
some police forces that are failing
um and that's not just about money
that's about quality and management and
Leadership
Sonia Sonia and Salma thank you both
very much indeed lovely to see you both
more from both of them in the 11 of
course right now let's check out the
weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well high pressure has given quiet dry
conditions for some time but there's the
potential for some heavy and possibly
thundery showers at the weekend as heat
and more unsettled conditions spread out
from the southwest it will be a fairly
dull start to the day with overnight
Cloud extending well into the West
clearer Skies over Ireland Western
Scotland West Wales and the Southwest
will give a chilly morning with some
patchy mist and fog the extensive Cloud
sheet over Central and Eastern parts of
the country will burn back more readily
this morning to leave a dry and sunny
day for many lingering Cloud around
Northern and Northeastern Coast will
make it feel cooler there will feel warm
though inland
sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up next on Sky News at 11 Prince
Harry takes to the stand in his hacking
trial against the mirror group singling
out Piers Morgan saying his alleged
involvement meeting feel physically sick
foreign
[Music]